The joe rogan experience.
I think we learned a lot today.
Um,
I did not know that you could make a fucking phone call with an artificial
intelligence thing that could say,
um,
and would make appointments for you and shit.
We all learned that,
that scared the shit out of me.
I didn't know about these Choo Choo train fake vagina attractions that these
kids are hacking as wacky kids.
I learned that I'm,
I am very confused when it comes to the future.
Very.
This stuff is,
I think this is all happening in front of us and I think it's insanely crazy and
insanely transformative and it's happening.
We don't have a fucking clue as to where it's going and there's nothing we can
do about it.
So we're all like,
well,
it is what it is.
I think it's nuts.
I think we are,
we're 20 years from the fucking matrix and we're seeing it happen.
We're seeing it happen right now in front of us.
We're seeing the little baby steps like,
Nah,
we're so far off.
Yeah.
I went to that whole thing the other day.
It was nothing.
Went to the conference?
Nah,
nothing impressed me.
Would you rather find out that we're about to be in it or that we've been in it
the whole time?
Which would make you more comfortable?
That's a very good question.
Damn,
that's a good question.
What do you think,
uh,
I think we're already in it.
Soc Two is that one,
well,
gun to the head,
what would you do?
Why would she say?
I think the reality itself is obviously some sort of weird thing because you're
looking at it,
you looking at it through your eyes.
Your eyes are determining the positions that things are in and what they look
like and where things are.
And these,
all these things that are going on around you all the time,
do you have no control of,
and they're everywhere all over the planet.
People living lives and you interface with those lives.
Occasionally you're just accustomed to the manner in which you do it.
So it seems normal.
But every night you close your eyes and you go unconscious.
And who knows what the fuck happens to your brain.
And then you wake up in the morning and you have to pee and you're struggling to
try to figure out what happened yesterday.
And then while this is happening,
your ex girlfriend's fucking your best friend from high school and they got
together and you know,
it's like,
can't believe Jamie left.
I mean he said he was gonna stay forever.
And then next thing you know like this is these,
all these lives intersect with each other all over the world.
It is kind of a hologram.
It's kind of a crazy react.
If,
if the,
if real life wasn't real,
it would be super interesting.
You'd be like,
look at the way life works.
Look at the way they breathe in air and breathe out carbon dioxide and the trees
breathe into carbon dioxide and breathe that air.
But they keep chopping down the trees.
They keep chopping down the trees,
they don't care.
They're like,
who cares?
I want paper.
I want to wipe my ass with a tree.
They just wipe their ass with trees.
Literally,
they grind millions of trees down every year and turned into pulp so they can
make paper to wipe their ass.
They literally wiped her ass with nature.
Why don't they just use soap and water?
No,
no.
I want a treat.
I want some pulverized tree to wipe my ass with tissue paper.
It's tissue paper.
It's fucking trees.
It's tissue paper really made out of trees.
It's a hundred percent yeah.
Synthetic tissue paper that's made out of like dolphin tears.
Somebody force,
what did they,
what?
It's like synthetic toilet papers.
That real shit.
I mean,
look,
they have tofu chicken,
right?
You don't think they have like some sort of an organic and make plastic out of
it,
I think.
Hmm.
Do they make hemp toilet paper and would it be too rough?
They'd be the best thing ever.
Free free bathroom tissue,
hemp 20 someone's doing it and so on to putting it together.
Sure.